SHOT.
GETS A LITTL
S RIGHT AROUND.
HE TAKES A BIT CONFUSED.
>> Announcer 2: THERE'S A IT AH
--
THEN IT STOPPED STRERE
MURPHY BACK ON A NOW TO McKAY.
McCABE SENDS IT INTO LOW.
SHOT -- HE WILL ELECT TO COVER.
A GREAMOVING IN.
--
INTERCEPTED, BUT THEY REGAIN
AND THEY WORKED THEIR WAY IN.
HERE WE GO. IT IN.
-- THE
PENALTY.
PAIN ON THE BRING GET
WAS SO GOOD AT GETTING
DEBRINCAT WENT OVER TO CLARIFY.
THAT'S WHAT WERE THE WHISTLE.
WE CAN ONLY GUESS AT THE MOMENT
WHAT THE REFS ARE LOOKING AT ON
THE iPAD.
IT'S NOT REVIEWABLE ANYWAY.
>> Referee: THE GOAL ON THE FO
STILL AS WELL.
NOT REALLY GOING TO IN FRONT.RE
NOT BECOME REVIEWABLE --.
>> Leah: THAT IS SHOT.
SCORES.
-- THE POWER-PLAY MARKER HAS
TIED THIS GAME AT 1.
>> Dominic: WHAT A PLAYRIGHT
THERE.
LITTLE STICK HOW HANDLINDIVIDUA
>> Leah:
>> Dominic: IT LO
WHEN IN.
GET ME TH THE LONG BOMB, CHICAG
SCORE.E.
IN THE -- AREA.